ninety percent of the world's adults
consume some form of caffeine every day
making it the most widely used
psychoactive drug on earth michael
pollan best-selling author of books on
plant pharmacology explains why a very
strong case can be made that caffeine
contributed to the enlightenment and the
age of reason and the industrial
revolution all of which required us to
think in much more focused linear terms
caffeine was an amazing aid to the rise
of capitalism
[Music]
compared to other beverages coffee is a
relative newcomer spreading slowly from
africa through the middle east and into
the west only a few centuries ago yet
it's hard to even imagine a world
without it before caffeine comes to
europe people were drunk or buzzed most
of the day people would have alcohol
with breakfast water was contaminated
with disease but alcohol because of the
fermentation process would kill a lot of
microbes so you gave your kids hard
cider in the morning there were beer
breaks on farms people adults on alcohol
are not going to be so rational are not
going to be so linear in their thinking
and are not going to be so energetic
coffee consumption along with tea and
chocolate all of which have caffeine
became widespread in europe in the 17th
century
and coffee houses popped up all over
london so there were coffee houses
dedicated to literature and writers and
poets would congregate there there was a
coffee house dedicated to selling stock
and that turned into the london stock
exchange eventually there was another
one dedicated to science tied to the
royal institution
where great scientists of the period
would get together and isaac newton was
a big coffee fan voltaire the
enlightenment figure apparently had 72
cups a day i don't know quite how you do
that
detero wrote the encyclopedia on
caffeine this new sober more civil drink
was changing the way people thought and
the way they worked once you're doing
work with machinery indoors doing double
entry bookkeeping and all that kind of
of head work alcohol is the wrong drug
and caffeine is the right drug caffeine
allows you also to break your ties to
the rhythms of the sun before caffeine
basically people started work when the
sun came up and stopped when it went
down
with caffeine and with light or gas
light you could have a night shift you
could now have an overnight shift it's
not hard to see a through line from
coffeeed up workers keeping up with the
pace of the machines in the factories
to the rise of office culture and the
establishment of the coffee break in the
1950s
caffeine has made us super productive
there's a very interesting body of
research that suggests that caffeine
does improve focus and memory and the
ability to learn so it seems to help us
lock in memories as for focus it
increases our ability to concentrate on
a task it's incredibly important for
modern work and of course caffeine also
gives us a burst of energy but how
exactly coffee has less than five
calories caffeine seems to be in
violation of the laws of thermodynamics
essentially caffeine borrows energy from
your future and gives it to you in the
present caffeine occupies a receptor
that normally is occupied by a chemical
called adenosine and this is the
chemical that over the course of the day
builds up and makes you feel tired and
prepares the brain for sleep caffeine
gets in there and blocks that receptor
so you never feel that tiredness right
and that's the catch caffeine messes
with your sleep because four to six
hours after you drink it half of it is
still swirling around in your body but
even if you cut it out earlier in the
day the quality of your sleep may suffer
not the quantity necessarily but the
quality by by which i mean your deep
sleep your slow wave sleep a kind of
sleep that's dreamless and very deep and
is very important to kind of brain
hygiene it's where your brain kind of
takes out the garbage every night and
and cleans up the desktop
and that kind of sleep suffers there's
no free lunch right in nature and in
medicine so is the price we pay for poor
sleep worth the benefits that caffeine
gives us there have been decades of
research into caffeine the current
research is that on balance it
contributes much more to your health
than it takes away and that it's
protective against many kinds of cancer
cardiovascular disease parkinson's
dementia in the american diet coffee and
tea represent the single biggest source
of antioxidants and antioxidants are
very important to cellular health and
preventing cancer and we eat so few
plants so few vegetables and fruit in
this country that we're getting most of
those antioxidants from coffee and tea
it's kind of remarkable that it has such
a clean bill of health with that one
exception of what it does to your sleep
or what it can do to your sleep right
caffeine ruins our sleep so that the
next morning we reach for more caffeine
and the cycle of addiction continues you
know we tend to moralize addiction but
is it really a bad thing to be dependent
on a plant
that you have easy access to you can
afford that isn't ruining your life and
is giving you some benefit the way in
which individuals are addicted to
caffeine is mirrored in our society we
have organized our society in such a way
with like globe spanning trade working
long hours and changing the climate and
changing the environment we have created
a world in which caffeine is
indispensable and therefore the coffee
plant and the tea plant are
indispensable and we've created exactly
the world they need in which to thrive
so
i can't think of a more clever
evolutionary strategy
[Music]
you